Aww yeah! Let's learn English with Justin
Bieber and his hit new song "Yummy"!
Yeah, you got that yummy, yum
That yummy, yum
That yummy, yummy
So after a long time of
not putting out any record Justin is
finally back with a new album and do you
know what yummy means? now, "yummy" means
delicious, but it can also have another
connotation. Let's look at what Justin
says this song is about in a recent
interview on The Ellen Show
-"Yummy", um, what does that mean exactly?
I mean I think I know but but what were
you thinking of when you wrote that
yummy?
My sex life.
Okay, that's what I thought it was.
So this song is full of
some fantastic vocabulary and
expressions to improve your English but
it goes without saying that the topics
discussed in the song may not be for
everyone, so if you're looking for
something more appropriate
then you might want to check out one of
the lessons in this playlist. Otherwise
let's check out the song that Justin
wrote for his wife Haley Baldwin
So before we get into learning all of the most
important information from this song
I want to let you know that if you're new here
every week we make fun lessons
just like this one with your favorite songs, series, movies and more
so that you can understand fast speaking natives
without getting lost, without missing the jokes
and without subtitles.
Like Tengis, who said that our videos helped him to increase his TOEFL score.
We'll help you to reach your goals learning English too.
All you have to do is hit the subscribe button and the bell down below so you don't miss any of our new lessons
Hey do you want to learn the way that natives really speak, like you just have here?
Well, the most fun way to do it is with our Fluent with Friends course!
Now in this forty-eight week
course you will master the principles of
native connected speech alongside the
first two seasons of the TV series
Friends, with twenty plus page PDF power
lessons, vocabulary memorization software,
access to our fluency circle global
community and so much more! And you
can try for free right now with our
three-part master class, what are you
waiting for? just click up here or down
in the description below and you can learn
more and sign for that right now.
Yo, do you love singing and dancing while you learn English?
well then all of
the lessons in this playlist are perfect for you
You can check that out after you
finish this video by clicking up here or
down in the description below.
So did you enjoy learning English with
Justin Bieber?
Well if you would like us
to make more lessons with Justin songs
or interviews be sure to let us know by
giving this video a like down below and
you can continue learning with the songs
you love in this playlist now it's time
to go beyond the classroom and live your English!
Aww yeah!